like dim ain't gonna get apologies David
you just saying you're not black enough
guess what there's no coming back
I've been found these guys for years
they've over three million subscribers
on YouTube yes you can go check out
their dates they're an Austin on October
7th San Antonio go to official
hodgetwins comm follow them at
hodgetwins and you can just search them
on youtube if they haven't been silenced
hodgetwins glad to have you both yeah we
can't well we can't we can't get enough
of the hodgetwins in our household
though we can't say this on the record
so you guys again out of the ordinary
bodybuilding channel not necessarily in
line with what we often talk about but
you've been hit by the youtubes d
monetization ad pocalypse we were gonna
meet with you when we were in Utah but
you know we got held up by the FBI now
you get explainable who don't know what
it is that you do on your channel and
how you guys got started because it's
kind of a new media success story yeah
so in California and I just got this
idea I was like I went to us definitely
kill the start a YouTube channel you
know he didn't say those words he said
let's beat some medians I was like wow I
thought he was smoking crack again but
yeah plenty well we started a YouTube
channel called it heart with just pretty
much just door whatever just random
skits and stuff like that and start it
weld into Doolin our current event
because to do comedy sketches PD more
than one person yeah and evil we did it
come as guilty about what to change all
the lights yes yes okay so before this
started you you guys were about a
hundred and ten pounds soaking wet and
then you realize man we got to lift some
weights and do our YouTube channel I
[Laughter]
remember you guys started at Planet
Fitness earlier which is the bane of my
existence but you know I'm not a big fan
but I remember you did a video on that
I'm banned from Planet
for life you know the true story
actually uh we back in the day man we
had a membership with Planet Fitness the
reason behind it was because we worked
at insurance company we got fire comes
with cussing in the YouTube video so we
had to give up our membership because
there's too expensive was like $25 yeah
no snow squat rack there yeah I was
kicked out for going in as a [ __ ] so
that's actually a little different
reason this was they had to hold the
whole men going to women's locker rooms
and so I just went in as a woman to
Planet Fitness they let me in totally
fine but by the third one I walked into
like Steven we know who you are you're
not a lot of Planet Fitness please ever
again
[Music]
I know but apparently they knew the
weight we had a youtube channel at that
point look we don't think you're being
sincere and I'm like but I am I am being
sincere I'm not feeling anymore I'm
Stephanie okay speaking of which you
guys did a lot of crap you just did a
DNA test on your channel from the black
community for what is it not not being
black is that the now my great-grandma
she was white yeah okay to don't that
black dude that's why we're here
but um we would say comments and our
videos and like black people's like you
know what I'm not comfortable [ __ ] I'm
not dark enough to be talking like this
plus they say we sound like some
rednecks move cuz we got a strong
Jackson
so they I sound like you'll send me Sam
like yes well there's a lot we talk with
a lot of common ground was actually
white Southerners and blacks from even
like urban Detroit a lot of the same
same terminology a lot of the same slang
and that big that comes from basically
sort of a common history here in the
United States hate to say it
some of that not so pretty with the
slavery but we got past we're doing
better 2017 us don't
well you okay so I don't know if I'm
outing you here but you said off air you
like oh yeah were you at the ben shapiro
thing in utah so you guys are aware of
him your your I wouldn't fans but you
you like some of his content yeah yeah I
watch his stuff on YouTube and yeah I
just like them hi put the V damn
liberals put them in a place where it's
like yeah like them ain't gonna get a
politic people say you're not black
enough
guess what there's no coming back now we
used to be CC liberal yeah but as we got
older us actually st. more for myself so
up here we like like right now we like I
would say we're leaning towards the
right I got one split in the right right
I got the other foot too used to be on
the left side so you're doing pistol
squats on the right and you haven't
figured out where you land yet you know
we just don't like how they paint
everything like I if they it's important
to race it stuff like that it's like
race it's like they use an angle to like
people keep people stuck as being
Democrats you know I don't erase prints
with y'all yeah yeah I mean you'll get
maybe this on your YouTube channel
they'll de monetize you but we're fine
you can say whatever you want here so
you've been hit obviously I remember we
met I've been watching you for a while
not a bodybuilder myself have always
been more of you know straight strength
trainer so you know practical purposes
but we can get into that another time
but we are you guys sent me a direct
message saying like yeah man we got to
monetize what kind of knew it but you
get that's proof man
it's like what we do is really pretty
pretty clean stuff and ever it happened
to us was that was that a part of kind
of your your awakening process do you
think you just saw the left trying to
shut everything down
yeah anything is controversial a tip is
true you talk about it unless you're a
little pushed everywhere pushing your
face on me every time I look at somebody
now what Australia becoming shows down
there got in the cab dc-8 we think punch
for president don't cry I'm like you do
yeah
it's like an infatuation with this guy's
Oh everybody talks about it it's like
yeah I'm like sick of you can't look at
nothing but I don't even look at say
anymore
it's just bad Trump 24/7 well I don't
look at it because I'm gonna see what
they're saying oh yeah I look at it with
bands over that toe yeah this is super
Merle dropping the Moab on ya what you
know it's funny actually when I first
moved to LA I was in Inglewood I was
sleeping on a cot in Inglewood and the
guy guy's name was I shouldn't say it
but he was black guy sometimes on his uh
on his floor he's like you can stay here
for a month and four days in we got into
an argument over politics and he's like
you got to go I was sleeping out of an
82 Datsun that I bought from a Cambodian
named Sonny and I remember I left told
the story because I was six hundred and
fifty two dollars because you know those
Cambodians are so cheap and then I I
said I don't have the fifty-two can I
write an IOU for $52
so really the black guy kicked me out
you know and I didn't hold it against
the entire race of people for a long
time I got past it the point is there
can be some healing
six days white bikini blood black black
brown me right out it was him and he
didn't say that it was because of
political argument but it was really
pretty clear and this was right before
Barack Obama eyes I don't even get into
it so let me ask you this you do live
shows now did you start doing live shows
because you didn't start out as like
stand-up comics no I started out as a as
an actor than stand-up comic in my
mid-teens on Benjamin who's often on the
show stand-up comedian was it more so
because of the D monetization on YouTube
and you found you guys have been pretty
smart with selling supplements doing a
lot of live shows and diversifying
outside of just YouTube so you haven't
been hit as hard did you always kind of
think okay what's the next step thinking
ahead
well we always love you stand up with
this we didn't have enough courage to go
out there and do it because going from
YouTube videos stand on the stage and
making people Apple just a microphone
man yeah that is no easy cup of tea
right everyone already knew you so if
you go out there it's like if you bomb
you know you get about five minutes of
grace as Colin Quinn says and then it's
like if you're not making us laugh
so you didn't have the benefit of just
starting and being a nobody you started
doing stand-up after you are known what
well we first started doing stand-up
though the whole money thing on YouTube
was great yeah I mean it we didn't have
to do stand-up we wanted to do stand-up
we really wanted to knock the money per
se but but thank God we did because
since we be doing stand-up that's the
only thing that's really keeping our
it's above water still as far as being
you know financially yeah we definitely
be in the red we would be in red
well then all your bad fans would say
okay they get a pass yeah you thank God
we did you didn't yeah we monetize
ourselves by selling clothing and
supplements if it wasn't for that I mean
if we would just laugh or get to man I
would be I would have to go get a job
yeah then you get fired because I'd see
your YouTube videos I'd say wow you're
hired
oh wait we saw your YouTube video on
Steve Harvey your fight your unhide yeah
immediately I'm hired yeah we've all
realized it's not kid Jared here he's
you can't be hired anywhere no go on
college campus anywhere now without
security not after what you just did
with an tyfa it's inside we really
wanted to meet up with you guys in in
utah but you know the FBI slows you down
when you have to turn over all this so
so do you deal at all in politics on
stage here's one thing I will say the
right kind of has the corner on fun now
lucky said because of political
correctness there are no youtubers on
the left where you're going oh I'm
aching to see their stand-up show that's
gonna be a rip-roaring riot you know
someone from The Young Turks oh what
will they say next
oh this is my seat so do you feel like
gives you a leg up I mean because you
don't care the right doesn't care at
this point so much who you offend I've
got to imagine that that's somewhat
liberating for you guys at least a
little we are pretty much well we just
pretty much tell a bunch of stories
about us being kids I got a killer
Caitlyn Jenner jokes let me hear it yeah
we just don't yeah we just we come from
a good place
yeah yeah now how do you balance being
on the road and obviously fitness but
you know staying in shape you just hit
road gyms do you bring do you bring
resistance bands with you what do you do
it's pretty rough I would say the time
with it again but most of time it's like
after healers show in the meat free yeah
I wiped out I was back to my hotel room
is I never we never realized who we
start doing on status shows like when
you onstage for an hour demand it's like
running a marathon oh yeah wow it is
taxing and then sleeping in the strange
beds and being blind and man it is rough
I remember we did a big 10 shows in
telephone yeah in five days oh geez
oh yeah cuz we had two shows back to
back days in San Diego then forever
some fallacies so you had to give some
stays leaves does one of you get
Cratchit na kijiye notice I always have
you know it's like this is these are my
diva requests stage microphone and for
45 minutes before the show a green room
because sometimes they'll do private
gigs I'll go on college campus and
they'll try to the meet-and-greet before
the show or something with you yeah it's
happened when you've been with me or
people are coming in their pitch and
sketches I'm like listen I don't know
don't be a jerk but I need 45 minutes
just to be by myself focus because it is
exhaust is one of you more cranky than
the other or you both just I imagine you
two like velociraptors in the kitchen
and that Jurassic Park contained just
constantly biting at each other's necks
do you know what um we come out on stage
the fans think that energy is so high
keeps us going like it's big what I
found to be very important when you're
torn you need a nice hot shower and you
show up to your show of your fans or
like you know then you love they'll it I
mean it keeps me going if you walk if
you walk into a show I've walked in
shows people seem like they're tired oh
it could be a drag because such shows
you the first couple of jokes you know
if it's will be a good show that yeah
and say Oh joking it doesn't hit like
[Laughter]
crowds is just it's kind of weird
because all you froze again
oh I froze well you know Hassan yeah if
you just show this is almost more funny
for the show can you guys hear me or no
I don't even think they can hear you go
oh all right yeah I was gonna say you
know I had that actually so just you
know but act like we can't that's better
for the show I I had that for a while
when I was young or that was nineteen
and I won a myspace comedy contest it
was called so you think you're funny and
you know what the prize was I got to
perform with black boy two eyes and
Bruce Bruce yeah no money though but
just imagine me opening up for Bru
brew and black boys that crowd was okay
I realize none of these jokes work and I
just joked about how white I was and I
didn't realize this speaking of the
racial healing I had to introduce Bruce
Bruce and I would introduce was like any
other stand-up show I look around I'm
selling I'm thinking like oh he had a
heart attack in the green room like he's
not coming out he's dead he came out
with an entourage like Mike Tyson and he
walked out slowly and it would have like
you know blaring hip-hop and he'd have a
full entourage and he would take a
minimum of a minute and a half to get to
the stage and the light McCallum so I'm
just this lone white kid 19 years old
yeah it is the most awkward thing and
you realize really early the audience is
honest you like this isn't gonna work
yeah
yeah it is crazy - he has a black
audience oh my god audience yeah I
oughta slap people you know yes so that
we have a black audience but I would say
sympathy audience and white Asian
Hispanic and then I will say 5% black
yeah well after the DNA test maybe
you'll get it up to six you know what I
was wrong about them man probably
thinking my whole purpose cuz in DNA
test all right it is official hodgetwins
dot-com and they have some good training
advice over there - I know you're you're
you're inundated with YouTube now with
just a whole bunch of horrible training
tips from people who are loaded to the
juice loaded to the gills with juice but
they swear that they're not you can
follow that hodge twins
hey it's I didn't even go I know I don't
know which ones Keith which ones Kevin
thank you guys and well yeah let's be
honest you're interchangeable at this
point and cut
come back soon guys okay hey hey boy
let's go go stay the play to the me
please
II know some people have no reason he
was like okay he's looking I tell you
what I'm gonna say I'm gonna give you
the out and play that music will let him
go let him come back next time do the
Pledge of Allegiance that's how we'll
live
hey did you enjoy this video here's the
thing you wrote you're here this is the
end of it so we don't care cuz you
already watched it but if you really
didn't like it and you want to justify
it leave a comment below telling us why
you didn't like the video and if you
liked us let us know and subscribe to
the channel because that lets the
overlords at YouTube know that you know
what you're alright